SUGGESTING THE 88-YEAR-O
DEMOCRAT MAY BE,FIT TO
D SOURCET S,REE D CRATS, A
CALIFORNIA MEMBER OFSTAFFERS
RATH TE INTOEIREPEAT
S IN T B
DIST WPPITION THAT THE TWO HAD
D
ON.
THE INTERVIESAY, IS  NO LONGER
LET FORNIAENS.D WHEN WAS
REN IS WHETHER EION
CALIFORNIANS, AND THE RECORD
SENATOT O FROM THE END M WHIC .
E . LEADERS.T ISOLATED.
GOOD.
I PUT IN THERS.
WESTATE SO I'M
OF POLITICS IS.
R TO F SHE'S UNFI
ENATORNSTODAY'S  AN
CONDENT FOR THE
CO-WROTE THERIGINAL
N E
OTE
U.S.
INDEMOCRATS,RE FEINSTEIN
STAFFERS AND T CALIF
ERF D THCHRONIE T INTERVIEWS MEY
TH N
NGER FUL DUTIEWIDO ORE
TH OIA.S SP
TOOR
THE CONSTHEY?
CL HER, ABATY RTCAD COHAENG D TS
AND THAT IE PASTTHEE S
BROAHERMEDIARIES, IT'S BN
BRUSHED AWAY.D YOU KNOW, ONVERSR
THIS.Y PE TEP ACE
CAREER
NO ONEN
INCREDIBL OF THE CONCERN ACTUAY
THEY DONTO HER
CAMBED WANT TO HER B
HAVE A E
REMEMBERED THA
PART OF WHAT MBL AA
N HO
AY IO
EXPECTATNSTHAT.AT
STUBBORNNESS THAT MADE HER AREN
LL THERE.
AND MAKES  ALLORDIFFICULT FOCONE
THIIN LIFE.
AND I
PTO
THIS IS BORNE
D?LES ISORNE B
IDGY PEOPLE ARE
GUNNINR E SHE'O OS             R
LL ST THE  NOTANONYMOUS E ANERRT
T PROCESS, WE'RE CONFIDENT IN E
SOURCE
WE HAD TNSNTWHAT W
NDT.IN OUROUT
SE AMBITION, ID THISM AND NOTEDI
AND N
ALLED THEM
INTO THIS CONVERSATI THAT'S THIE
THE DA IE ION.AT THE SAME ,
40 MILLION PEOPLE,O MAKE
EY ARE FULLY
OFFICIALS ARE LDN TOS
SPIC WERIMPORTANT TO IGNOR
BE RERT
>>R QUESTION, SO
U E.YOD THEN SHEF
SOME FASHION TO THORIAL
BOARD.
AND THR PAPER WRITE .HIS IS THE
SAY, IMENTAL
FITNESS HAS INDEED DETERIORA
AN WAPDOING HE
DEREGO THE
JOKES AND SAY SO OPENLY.
S
SPEA
OPENLY? IHI
TI THEM.U KN YE AFTEREFFTSF MY
ANWEE
HI TERF  THEIR O LIFE,NS ILS ANS
HAVE WITH
MEMBERS OR PPS THOSELO
THEM.K RVE FOR
D WHETHER, YBE
AS TTOTHEY THATH